Minnesota Town's entire police force
resigns leaving Chief with zero
prospects good Hugh Minnesota a small
town in the Southeastern part of the
State lost its entire police force after
the chief and and other members of the
force handed in the resignations
I think we're a little bit blindsided by
it but we're resilient we're going to
move forward
this has been three weeks now we have
zero applicants zero prospects I've
called every PD around for the youngest
guys out there getting in the game
nobody's getting in the game if you want
to keep the PD and this is something we
want to keep going with something needs
to change dramatically and drastically
and it's got to happen now one good Hugh
city council member praised the police
force for maintaining Law and Order in
the town of Goodhue I can probably speak
for everyone when I say they provided
excellent Safety and Security to our
community Etc et cetera blah blah blah
and uh nobody wants to be a cop
so when I talk about what comes next
confidence people believing in federal
government
yeah at least in this small town and
it's not the only place we're saying
things like this this is just the most
extreme example the entire police force
resigning we've seen similar things
before of Mass resignations from various
police departments what happens to a
town when they have no cops
well we could already see what's
happening to LA and New York when the
law says you can't arrest these people
when people aren't allowed to defend
themselves or their property but what
happens when there's no cops
it's not what people think people assume
if there's no police officers then
you're going to have rampant crime
actually I think in small towns it'll be
the inverse you know why
because if there's no cops to arrest a
criminal at all the criminals already
aren't getting arrested that means
there's no one to arrest the person for
defending themselves
which means in small towns with zero
police people will start arming up and
then if someone comes in to rob their
store they get shot then this person
says there's no government I don't abide
by any of that I don't know what they're
talking about they abandoned us a long
time ago and this leads to social
breakdown and and Decay but maybe It
ultimately leads to more Community
Building because if there's no cops
people have to go talk to their
neighbors to figure out how they're
protecting each protecting each other
yeah I think becoming a cop through
necessity kind of is more noble than
doing it for a paycheck doing it because
you we truly need protection and then
calling the greatest among us to protect
is like that's a calling you know it's
important to note the population of this
uh City it is a city is only
1176. did you see how many cops resigned
was that like five it was probably five
yeah you know the entire police force is
like five but I mean if you know they
still resigned what do they resign for
uh it doesn't I don't it doesn't I don't
think it says
so how do you feel about the law that's
being passed in Chicago or Illinois
where illegal immigrants can actually
become police officers now at the first
I've heard of it
well illegal yeah illegal immigrants low
paying competition from larger cities is
was a big component so they're getting
jobs in other cities they're getting
paid more going to bigger cities I mean
that makes sense once this law you
mentioned in Chicago do you know what
the name of it is or anything in
Illinois it's being passed here in uh
shortly I think it's November
um if you are an illegal immigrant you
can
also be a police officer oh yes that's
right that's JB pritzker's new law okay
non-citizen law enforcement yeah
so should we fill Minnesota's town with
five illegal immigrants not all at once
if you can help it maybe introduce one
at a time and let them get socialized
and you should I think that people
should like you know be like in the
United States legally before they start
working for the United States well could
you go to like that's a good idea yeah I
mean could you go to any country in the
world and just become a police officer
tomorrow confident you that's a no it
could be a way to earn something so why
do we allow it no I don't know about
that either I I don't think we should I
I honestly like like I'm super for like
point B is are we this desperate right
our police officers like leaving the
police force and and record numbers if I
understand correctly I I mean I don't
have any you know data on it but like
that's what it seems like this is a
house bill 3751 in case people want to
look into it
um I wonder about like letting people
earn ways for people to earn citizenship
um and if joining military a lot of like
they do that you you can do that by
joining the military and I think the
military is one thing but but just
coming to the United States and and
joining a civilian police force I think
is different yeah I've never heard up to
this point that that would function but
maybe it would be a good way too you can
buy citizenship
yeah yeah one thing that people do is
they'll uh you don't need to be an
American citizen to start a company in
the United States so they'll start a
company then they'll hire themselves and
use that as justification for yeah
there's also economic uh uh visas where
it's like if you have a certain amount
of money invested then you get to stay
in the country I have no problem with
people coming to the us that are that
are you know looking to
improve their situation and and start a
business or whatever it's like that's
that's that's what I mean that was it's
one of the wonderful things about the
United States is is we've always been
open to people that want to come and
want to be you know want to be free and
and take advantage of the fact that we
are a mostly free country you know it
the problem is when it's like oh you
know we're just gonna have people that
we're going to allow people to come in
and then as soon as you get here we're
going to get you onto some kind of
government uh you know subsidies or
government program or something that's
the bad thing before American citizens
yeah Lily no just at all like if you're
here illegally you shouldn't be getting
but they are getting it before American
citizens yeah true but they shouldn't be
getting it at all not about I I don't
think that there's a before U.S citizens
kind of thing in that I don't think if
you're here legally you shouldn't be
getting 100 like unemployment and stuff
like that yeah you shouldn't be getting
that those things you don't eat I
understand there are people like oh if
someone's here they're paying taxes Etc
you know I get it that is true but to me
it's just not convincing it's like if
you're here illegally you shouldn't get
service free services from the
government Beyond this the immediate
stuff that everyone else gets like if
you show up at a hospital and you need
an emergency you need emergency care
that shouldn't mean that you get sent to
the police and get sent you know get
sent out of the country if you if you
you know if you're if you need the
police to help to help you the police
shouldn't automatically wrap you up like
the regular B cops but you know there's
a whole lot of DHS out there and they do
a whole lot of messing with your average
people when they could be looking for
people that that have you know skipped
their uh their their hearings for
whatever they call it when they come to
the to the country or whatever so you
know I wonder what percentage of illegal
immigrants are actually like superheroes
that
but like people that are like sub super
human intelligent like very very top of
the level they would have came here
legally yeah that's that's they they
have a brain to come here legally
they're probably well lost in my opinion
successful in their own country and then
they buy a private jet to fly in and get
a special class Visa one of the bad
things about people that come to the
United States the people like that that
come to the United States if they're
successful people that are coming to the
U.S from under you know uh uh people
from countries that have lower economic
you know output and stuff like that the
people that are successful they're
needed in those countries so if you're
like a doctor in you know somewhere in
in Africa and they're and you're a good
doctor in the major city in in you know
whatever African country you're talking
about and you leave to come to the U.S
that's better for you but there's a lot
of people in Africa that we're relying
on you being the good doctor after in
town taking care of them so there's it's
a double-edged sword when you're like oh
we're gonna do we're gonna accept we
want to accept good people that can
contribute to our society if you're
taking them from the third world country
which they have every reason to want to
get out of there I get it but if you're
taken from third world countries those
people are the ones that are the most
necessary to help build those countries
that they're coming from so it's you
know it's just a a struggle idea that
you that people need to think about when
it comes to immigration brain drain
causing brain drain on other countries
yep yeah it's definitely uh you could
argue that it's International defense to
have the best brains damn be the
consequences but uh I get what you're
saying we're a holistic world and we
should support other nations as well
yeah I mean my grandparents came here
the legal way I mean they weren't
doctors or anything but they came to
this country for a better life and in
back in the 19 whatever was 70s and they
were like what do I got to do to be a
U.S citizen what is the what what I
gotta do just tell me what I gotta do
and they did it that's it they were
normal people
they did it they became citizens they
raised their families they came here you
know so I'm not saying there's no good
people in that Bunch that are coming
here illegally but I'm also not saying a
majority of them are probably the rock
stars that you're talking about I think
that makes sense because it's super
super phenomenal humans will probably
figure out how to get here legally of
course because they're not going to want
to go across the Rio Grande but when
they have all these skills they're going
to want to be like hey how do I how do I
come here so I can because I got all
these skills and we'll be like
absolutely like come on over if you're
trying to smuggle kids across the board
or you're probably not the person that
should be here and if you're one of
those kids it basically it doesn't even
matter if you're like a 16 year old but
you're like a super genius and you're
getting smuggled across the border like
that's not I don't know yeah it's a lot
it's a tangent yeah
it's unfortunate the cop thing in New
York I feel like
man
dude they've already got non-citizen
voting in place in parts of California
and New York
that's it global global citizen One
World Government whatever you want do
you think there's value to letting
people earn citizenship through serving
in like civil like police and fire
department no
fire department maybe not law
enforcement law enforcement you you I
think you've got to be a citizen
fire department though I can respect
that and say okay you know we'll put you
on the fire department or something like
that but the problem is there are people
here who want to be firefighters and get
paid to do it yeah there's there's huge
weightless it's very difficult in big
cities to get that job it's a good job
it's I'm I guess in situations like what
we got in Minnesota where five they
can't hire a police force like would it
be reasonable to hire no yeah to have a
non-citizen enforce the law that's
that's that's dramatic erosion of of
your country your social standards your
law
yeah a guy putting out fire is totally
different right they're saving people I
mean yeah and just putting fires on you
you don't need to speak English or no
American Doctrine to put out a fire you
do you probably should know probably you
should at least
with the with like the lieutenant or
captain on scene who's instructing
people on what to do to put the fight
yeah you got to speak English
no you don't need to know American
Doctrine to put out a fire it's a
universal language get the hose buckets
yeah I mean there's yeah five people we
just need five firefighters for this
town we got this I think there you go we
can cover this police force just this
table
I think we see a lot of this stuff uh
cops resigning because of what happens I
mean it's Minnesota I wouldn't be
surprised if a component of this people
are resigning because of what happened
to TaoTao
oh the cop who was simply present while
George Floyd was killed God he got what
five years so who wants to be a cop
nobody
especially when you're you know I have
family members that are were and are
cops in Chicago and
during the riots during the BLM stuff
they they got bricks thrown at their
foreheads and they were the same cops
that were playing basketball with the
kids in the inner communities so they're
like why am I doing this anymore like I
I am a good cop I don't need bricks
thrown at my head and then no support
from our chief
I'm out
bye you guys listening anybody want to
be a cop put a two in the chat if you
want to be a cop
and then put a nine if you don't want to
be okay yeah put a nine if you're not
interested there's got to be an
alternative number and he's like two
there's gonna be people one I guess
people gotta wannabe cops to be a cop
like you've got to have faith in the
system be like I love this city so much
that I want to make it safe that's one
of them that's the real like caustic and
and bad thing about the a cab sentiment
it's not just that that like you know
you have issues with the existing cops
if your whole Community has the attitude
that all cops are bastards who wants to
help who wants to be a cop and the
places that have the people that are
screaming a cab the most are places that
need the cops the worst
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time